why do i put that cover on the nub
bro it's to protect the bone duh
i'm just kidding that's my skin
so i know you guys all know what razor
scooters are
when i was about 10 years old me and all
my friends got razor scooters for
christmas
we were all beyond excited we would go
outside in the freezing cold and ride
our scooters around
now i know you guys know about the
ultimate scooter ankle
so as we were trying to do all these new
cool tricks we caught a few scooters to
the ankle
so after a few scooters to the ankle me
and my friends decided it would be cool
to have a challenge
we wanted to see who could take the most
hits to the ankle before quitting
and there we go swinging the scooters
around knocking ourselves into the
ankles
there was three of us and after about
two hits one of my friends was out
no more so it was just me and my other
friend left he did it about five times
on my sixth time i swung the scooter
around and it was a little bit too high
and shot my leg clean off
i'm just kidding guys i had cancer
so what did i do on my last day with two
legs
that is an amazing question before we
get into it it would mean a lot if you
guys could leave a like on the video and
follow me if you're not following me
already
so the amputation was planned and i knew
i was going to be losing my leg
but at this point obviously my leg was
in pretty bad condition so i really
couldn't do much
so pretty much all i did was stay inside
and kind of just take time to process
the whole situation
however i did take a video of my leg the
night before so i could go look back at
it in the future so i'm going to show
that to you guys now
[Music]
how do you shower i never really wanted
to talk about this before because i know
it's kind of different and
like in a way it can be seen as weird
but if you guys don't mind leave a like
on the video
so as you guys know i'm missing my right
leg and because i'm missing my leg
i can't really get in the shower so i
just don't shower
but fortunately enough for me i don't
really get sweaty or stinky or like
musty or anything
so i don't really have to worry about
smelling bad so yeah
do i like having one leg that is an
amazing question
so truthfully when i found out that i
was gonna lose my leg i was pretty upset
about it
i thought it would have a really big
negative impact on my life and that it
would just make my life so much more
difficult
but honestly i think it's one of the
best things that's ever happened to me
now you're probably really confused by
that so let me explain
so first of all losing my leg really
motivated me to lose weight
so as most of you know growing up i was
really overweight and losing my leg
really pushed me and motivated me to
kind of make that
change and lose that weight losing my
leg has also allowed me to reach out to
and connect with a lot of different
people
i've met many great people throughout my
journey and i'm very thankful for each
and every one of them
i've also been given this platform on
tick tock where i've been able to
inspire and motivate thousands of people
and i just think that's great i think at
the end of the day it's worth it
to everyone who watched this video all
the way through i hope you have an
amazing day
can you grow any taller with one leg bro
i freaking wish
i lost my leg when i was 15 years old i
was
5'4 with a lot of potential and i've
been a 5'4 ever since
yeah hate to see it yeah i hate to see
it so a few days ago i made a video
about this and i showed you guys how i
drive
yesterday i made a video of me actually
driving and it got taken down for
community guidelines violations
so here we are foot on the brake foot on
the gas
brake gas i would show you guys a video
of me driving but tick tock won't allow
it
you